three two one
creating this hit took an air
pressurizer a gnarly prosthetic and a
special blood formula
making actors project gush and burst out
blood on camera isn't just about gore
these bloody scenes require careful
research and artistic flair
to find out how they do it we went to
brett schmidt and greg pikolsky the
special effects makeup artist at spfx
studio
they've created graphic injuries for mob
dramas like the irishman medical shows
like new amsterdam and action movies
like sicario day of the soldado
it all starts with the actual
prosthetics the hardest part of creating
wounds is building the look of depth
prosthetic makeup is an additive process
so you can only add you can't take away
but when you look at a wound you're
supposed to be looking into the body the
prosthetic needs to be thick enough to
create that effect but it also has to
work into the rest of the person's body
and that's why a lot of times for
effects
that have you know lacerations or even
bullet holes you'll actually have a
prosthetic that is
an entire torso just to create the
effect of this small bullet wound in
sicario day of the soldado brett and
greg had to sculpt a prosthetic that
covered most of the actor's shoulder
for this laceration prosthetic from new
amsterdam they were able to build up a
thickness that subtly ramps up toward
the laceration
because this scene required a lot of
blood the prosthetic also had to be
thick enough to hide a medium-sized
vinyl tube
for smaller wounds brett and greg might
use one of these tiny tubes these can be
hidden in actors hair or even a pair of
glasses like they did in this scene from
sicario day of the soldado
to hide the larger tubes however they
had to sculpt a special channel in the
prosthetic you don't want to put a tube
in you know that creates a bulge or
anything like that that'll give away the
effect on set they hid the rest of the
tube underneath and behind the actress
how the blood comes out of the tube
depends on what you use to power it
in this scene a piece of shrapnel has
hit a patient's artery to create the
kind of spray that results from an
artery rupture the blood has to be
released at a high pressure out of a
centralized location like you see in
this test run with water
they get that effect using this little
device
this is a tiny little garden sprayer
that's usually used for spraying various
chemicals on your flowers or whatnot
after they prime the line with some
pre-existing blood they let out the
blood in a pulsing motion to emulate
real arterial bleeding which coincides
with a person's heartbeat
the color and type of fake blood is also
key arterial blood is fresher and more
oxygenated than the blood in your veins
so this scene calls for a more vibrant
light red
a lot of times what we look for in the
color of blood is like that orangy
yellowy hue for an older or partly dried
wound they'd use this brownish red gel
which has a thicker texture to emulate
scabbing
but for fresh injuries like this one the
most convincing fake typically contains
compounds called opacifiers which make
it opaque so it looks better on screen
because anybody who's ever seen a really
cheesy horror movie will see that clear
like fruit punch colored looking blood
that is dripping off the end of a
machete or something which looks like
absolute trash
while some wounds have a more focused
source of blood and other injuries you'd
want to see the entire length of the
wound bleeding like a throat slit or a
slash to the abdomen
so basically on this one we're going to
try to get like a nice curtain of blood
instead of just one you know centralized
location
i'm just cutting little slits in the
tube this will create the more
horizontal flow you see here in the test
run they're doing with water
the prosthetic can then be glued onto
the actor's body and blended in to get a
slow continuous curtain of blood seeping
out of an abdomen slash they went with a
simple 60 milliliter syringe
put the tube on the end of this fill it
up with blood and you can
just
let it bleed slowly the team also had to
adjust the type of fake blood for this
injury opting for one with ingredients
called surfactants which prevent it from
beating over a rubber surface like the
prosthetic
real blood doesn't do that it smears it
leaves trails without any beatings what
about when you don't want a continuous
flow of blood just one dramatic burst
these air hits are something you might
see in a samurai film or a quentin
tarantino fight scene for this effect
brett and greg went with what they call
a pressure popper
this flat piece goes up against the
wardrobe and then the the tubing runs
you know down the wardrobe down the leg
down whatever it is this air chamber
releases all the air through a quick
release valve which if they set the
pressure high enough it'll just vaporize
the blood it took a couple of test runs
to get the effect as dramatic as we
wanted
all right so we'll do more pressure but
maybe 40 yeah
three
two one
the key was using a lot of blood
for the full effect though you'd need to
see this in slow mo
these decisions are affected by the
style of the edit too if they know a hit
will only be shown with a quick reveal
like in a fast cutting action sequence
greg and brett will lean towards going
bigger with the effect if you do
something more on the subtle side
especially when it's atomized or coming
out in a stream unless it's backlit a
lot of times you won't see it the blood
will get lost
equally dramatic is the classic gunshot
to the head but that effect calls for a
more concentrated blood hit and an
attention to texture
to mimic the effect of a bullet they
attach the pressurizer to a blood cannon
a system powered by air that doesn't
need to be attached to a prosthetic
blood cannons allow for more control
over where the blood goes perfect when
you want to land on the wall in a
specific spot behind an actor and since
we wanted a thicker hit of blood against
the wall they added copious amounts of
one of their favorite ingredients
ultra slime a product made from a
mystery recipe that gives everything the
stringy consistency of mucus
if you've ever seen like ghostbusters or
any 80s movie ever it's the stuff that
makes everything look disgusting it's so
stringy that you actually have to cut it
with scissors introducing these new
textures took some trial and error
though
one
two three
too much slime and we didn't get enough
of a splatter looks like someone just
talked up along so they revised the
formula and added pieces of banana to
emulate brain bits three two
i think a banana bit hit my head
in my eye
to make this last one extra dramatic
greg used a trick from saving private
ryan
if you watch it slowly a lot of the
actors who get shot usually like in a
scene where there's a lot getting shot
as they get shot they like spit blood
out because it's just another element
it might be over the top but sometimes
that's the point
anything from horror to medical
and anything in between when you're
making a movie you have that you have
that creative freedom to kind of push
things and you know and have fun with it